on a senti dans votre discours une
volonté plus que de dialogue plus que
d'une main tandis qu'une grande
ouverture de porte
vis-à-vis des études au court l'élu
local que vous êtes à parler puisque
l'une y est les deux ont parlé ensemble
le président de la république comme vous
le savez a annoncé un pacte gironde a et
donc annoncé sa volonté de faire
travailler ensemble
l'état et les collectivités locales ce
n'était pas dans sa bouche qu'un simple
discours c'était une vraie volonté
il s'est exprimé devant les préfets il
ya une dizaine de jours et il l'aura
fait passer ce message il faut
déconcentrer l'état de manière à ce que
vous puissiez discuter avec les
collectivités locales
ça veut dire plus de moyens on a compris
ce matin dans discours du premier
ministre qui a donné une enveloppe
budgétaire un peu plus importante
par exemple si on prend un cas concret
pour vous la police de sécurité
quotidienne qui va voir le jour d'ici
peu
elle sera bien financées il n'y aura pas
de contribution de la part des élus
locaux
ah non évidemment il s'agit pas pour
l'état de se défausser sur les
collectivités locales
c'est un jeu que je connais depuis très
longtemps non il s'agit de pas de
prendre notre part et de faire en sorte
simplement d'avoir un travail avec les
maires voit bien aujourd'hui que les
acteurs de la sécurité
c'est évidemment les forces publiques
mais c'est en même temps les polices
municipales que même plus largement pour
organiser les grands événements ce sont
les agents de sécurité et donc dans
quelques temps nous allons lancer une
réflexion avec l'ensemble des acteurs
pour essayer de construire une sécurité
au quotidien
le dialogue a repris est ce que vous
estimez que la bague que l'on traverse
avec ses les élections sénatoriales qui
arrive dès dimanche après ces élections
le dialogue sera finalement jusque
apaisé sera redevenu normal je pense que
nous portons le projet d'une france
apaisée
on a vu pendant la campagne électorale
des présidentielles
combien il y avait dans cette france de
tensions de colère et donc nous voulons
surmonter ces tensions et cette colère
pour que dans cinq ans la france soit
comme un certain nombre de nos grandes
villes
plus détendu plus joyeuse plus prospère
plus agréable plus propice au bonheur
vous regardez les élections dimanche
prochain c'est les élections qui sont
être largement déterminée par les
élections municipales et régionales
cantonales passées et donc pour en
marche qui n'existait pas à cette époque
là évidemment il peut pas y avoir de
grandes surprises
je pense que on devrait peut-être
devrait être entre 40 et 50 membres du
groupe evian elles ne seront pas très
bonnes pour la gauche seront favorables
à la droite mais c'est plutôt le
rétroviseur que l'avenir